bientôt lancer squeeze aujourd'hui c'est
le retour d'un personnage incroyable et
terriblement diabolique a conduit la
torre il ya une mise à jour et on est
sur une toute nouvelle map et c'est une
app fait par les développeurs du jeu et
pas par des mecs comme moi ou comme
comme lui je sais pas bref c'est pas si
on a toute une ville à explorer au lard
est déjà tu te détends direct avec ton
polo bleu c'est plus à la mode donc ça
suffit et tu mets donc non mais pleure
pas pleure pas pleure pas tout va bien
se passer la chaleur c'est ça qui te
fait pleurer allez allez un petit peu
d'eau pour toi
t'inquiète pas hop la nasa fait le
plaisir de revenir sur ce jeu ça fait
tellement longtemps que j'ai pas joué
eh ben elle arrive dans cette ville plus
tard un hélicoptère [ __ ] qui soit un
gros kiff d'ailleurs j'avais des copains
non aux [ __ ] j'y ai cru mais non on
est un vieux banc tout moche
saloperie 2 bon on va essayer de trouver
les petites statuettes qui développent
des nouvelles chèvre on a quoi ici je
les sens et c'est que ça devienne
grappling tunes ok j'ai débloqué le chef
de l'espace ça marche a dit qu'elle bat
l'orb alors bébé du tout mais regarde
d'où tu marches c'est quoi ça cette
manière faire un jogging allez tu viens
mon gars on va faire la grande roue
ensemble kaki que fait cet homme tu es
jaloux si ça tu veux venir les groupes
non tu vas te fait leur piège
non mais attendez moi je veux car l'eau
monte et au salvador
ok mon gars qu'est ce qui se passe de
manière à nous les chefs de fer manège
y'a pas moyen de monter dedans s'est
fait demander qu'est ce qu'on a ici sauf
and it is ok doit adopter c'est pas la
peine de me casser le dos parce que je
t'attrape et la chouette malonga je peux
pas jouer je veux jouer
bonjour je veux jouer oui oui vous les
noms mais pourquoi personne ne veut
jouer désormais à mon action je fous le
bordel dans l'attraction et pourquoi tu
pleures
ah ah ah je vais retrouver son ami pete
c'est ça revient moyen des là-dedans
bordel voilà est de monter sur cette
chambre soit alors déjà doucette fallu
monter sur mon dos comme ça et pourquoi
elle fait des ronds avec son pied mais
c'est pas moi qui regarde
tu es jaloux des jaloux des jalouses
pour ça qu'ils couvrent 1 et ben voilà
et ben toi aussi tu as un peu désormais
il s'appelle arbres ok mon dieu mais
bien tuer quelqu'un sous mes yeux puis
120 son problème coiffeuse à criminels
criminal j'aimais à l'eau et ses relevés
de la manière la plus stylée du groupe
wayne un ascenseur plutôt vite on va
rater l'ascenseur vite
l'ascenseur est à nous hopley allez
c'est parti on est tous les deux
ensemble entre quatre meilleurs à on
peut jouer à chat pervers on se met tous
devant ces partis beach je m'accroche au
cas où avec ma langue pour pas qu'on se
perde c'est parti à terme elles mêmes
qu'ils ont carrément pas du tout tendre
s'installe en attraction quoi c'est
parti s'amuse alors oui oui celle de
chez elle jugeait que toi bien
j'ai assez sur le jeu la route est
bloquée gisèle et lui il est pas du tout
choquée mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont des
arbustes [ __ ] mais tout le monde
échoue dans le jeu auprès de gisèle ça
part en couilles
gisèle oui gisen c'est toi c'est toi tu
lente et tonton arbustes gsm non désolé
pour le bleu mec gisèle tué mi-homme
mi-femme 1 et ça mérite que je te prête
à le jouer elle est géniale cette
nouvelle map il ya plein de trucs tu
veux faire les boutiques avec moi toi l
onda et cela que tu viens d'une
statuette
weight bicycle ménard mais attendez mais
mélange entre voisins belges y avait
juste monté sur bélon & start attendait
mais je veux retrouver mon vélo woippy
d'achat vitro un fait nous voilà
l'accouplement du mur toi tu pratiques
la position foetale mais on est copains
je voulais 2 allait bien il ajoute à
prendre combien fait une position
foetale tu fais comme ça et tu fais
savoir la position foetale
bon là c'est plus possible position
fille qui veut faire label auprès des
garçons et qui se courbent sas et la
rame aux attentes mais que vois-je de
l'argent je m'en vais avec ton argent
grotte cambrioleurs réseau le couple
amoureux
qu'est ce qui lui prend vous êtes tous
fous j'm'en va vite
non l'argent allez c'est bon je vais
vite ya peu latin cash only in fine sur
mon aide pour by some crac ameno mais
j'avais de l'argent juste avant excuse
moi tu as de l'argent
pas trop mais attends quand je tape
quelqu'un dans un rayon de 10 mètres ont
montré une crise cardiaque quoi à nantes
30 m alors il fait juste le pont non on
y danse dont je sais pas jamais au oui
non je pense pas qu'ils accepteront les
paiements par écran d'ordi oui on a de
l'argent c'est bon tu viens tu viens
voilà ce qu'est ce que je peux acheter
at simulator donc toi quand je te donne
de l'argent tu castel nuque a pas de
problème aux la classique out je pars
promet dollars lui redonner bon c'est un
peu technique des secours mais ça aurait
pu marcher
hoarau dieu dieu dégoûte jemâa genoux
devant ta puissance mais que vois-je
est-ce qu'on peut monter sur ouette
contre le matin non au oui à en croire
obama de monga attend fond ce maquereau
cheval en bateau sinon je sens qu'on va
partir vraiment aux couilles
j'arrive au tabou mais tu es nul là bas
on va les trouver quelque chose j'en
suis sûr une baleine attendait salut
baleine comment mettre dessus et il ya
un truc bien pas en tout cas cette boîte
oh non attendez il se passe quoi ici il
ya une fête la toile mais la baleine a
carrément éjecté mais voilà c'est
exactement là où je voulais atterrir
pour faire une pause café
et si on sort d'une course-poursuite
épique c'est dingue le plus ridicule que
j'ai vu de ma vie qu allez c'est parti
allez course poursuite mais non mais
partie cette fois chez comme on en fait
pas bon pardon bah oui mais voilà il
n'ya pas de soleil sur son vélo vous
allez bien si je voulais ch et je vous
tire et je vous emmène délicatement dans
l'eau pour effacer toute preuve de
crimes à il arrive c'est bon baleng au
global l éjecter mois et bientôt mais
elle fait même pas ça sur deux mais non
même fait complet mais [ __ ] baleine
c'est parce qu'ils étaient prévus au
hockey
[Musique]
oh mon dieu boîte de nuit et y
pardon je suis bien et puis j'ai dit
j'étais bien et puis j'ai des cheveux en
épi [ __ ] j'ai mon pass je vous passe
avec moi ok ça marche bon j'avoue
c'était une poubelle mais qu'est ce qui
se passe ici
ah d'accord ok le squat des gens xulu
c'est quoi ça je me fais frappés par des
gens tu connais pas la puissance des
chefs well well et meurt attention
attention attention ces moments c'est le
moment
oui oui
[ __ ] non oui ah non c'est bon waouh
stabilisation stabilisation
stabilisation non non les dragons go wi
trottoirs console bois comme ça merci
trottoir au pied il ya pas moyen d'y
aller avec un ascenseur attend des buts
ça se trouve je me fais chier mais l'ami
atria des ascenseurs mais oui michael
salut non mais pourquoi pourquoi tout de
suite vous le rejetez de dd que je vais
aller dans un groupe social tellement
faille via un jeu de console où tu
donnes maubeugeois augusto qu'aux jeux
watts c'est parce qu'ils étaient pris
peut-être her to paris est ce que par
exemple il est en train de faire une
dépression au bord de l'eau si je suis
sur rcf robots n'ont même pas fait
d'école y'a pas moyen de way alors là je
peux faire danser la voiture il dans ce
volant tout gel et des tours nîmes
offline vous êtes mort ah ouais donc
c'est moi alors ok je vole un vélo aller
mais non mais tu vois pas que j'essaie
depuis l'auteur vélo c'est parti
attention attention le saut non l'a
presque fait qu'il vient empoisonner ce
mec ça vient il devrait être en train de
faire un câlin et non il dort à côté
comme un petit bébé quoi ah il nous fait
peur il a maté n'est fait cela tu me
fais pas un dat ass au 1
what nathan mais pourquoi une telle plus
en plus il est mort noyé quoi voilà au
nom le retour de l'homme des bussian tu
ne tueras plus personne qu'est-ce qu'on
va par ici la cabane donner aux désolé
désolé mais qu'à trouver le meilleur
endroit pour qui fait ce soir échos là
je m'en vais voilà suicide c'est quoi
cet endroit on est dans un cimetière
leroux pardon pardon roi des fièvres
tiens qu'est tu vas me faire mon gars
moi je suis good for five mais arrête
arrête de m'attaquer insupportable avec
tombera en est là qu'est ce que c'est
que ça balding olten locked presley
mastur fait d'accord la minecraft gold
quoi est-ce qu'on peut l'enfermer c'est
ta punition pour pleurer depuis quatre
jours
c'est un sarcophage en enfer vraiment
opus et hop là c'est fini on va jouer
avec la crise si god qu'on a débloqué
tout à l'heure mais non mais non c'est
un [ __ ] de pingouins mon gars
donc en fait on glisse sur levante quoi
c'est ça allait la hotoie jour blessure
tombe à tout à l'heure vous guette tuba
ok tu me regardes man qu'est ce qui se
passe non respect de place on va se
caler la voilà c'est bon allez on y
arrive on y arrive on y arrive on y
arrive à lens mais bien c'est bon c'est
bon on est bien non non on avait lui
aussi savez j'écoute et freddy la
baleine va tout régler ton compte freddy
je t'amène un client bien les toits
faire laisse moi faire t'inquiète pas
freddy match bien s'occuper de toi
non mais freddy je pensais qu'on était
habile tous les deux et je te lâche à la
fête
voilà salut je veux un petit verre de
moi je veux revoir gisèle ça fait
longtemps
cette femme et gisèle mais alors
question mon dos et voilà les gens c'est
déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur la mise à
jour de bottines à tort j'espère que ça
vous aura plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé les deux ça fera plaisir et jeudi 7
plus de 3 à la fin de chaque vidéo et
qui craque complètement de lui même on
se retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo il faut bien de faire ça avec mes
doigts tu as tout le monde
[Musique]